قطار بوتين المدرع وملجا زيلينسكي تحت
الارض بين كياف وموسكو اختلفت وسائل
الحمايه المخصصه لزعيم البلدين زمن الحرب
بوتين يستعمل القطار خلال تنقلاته في جميع
انحاء روسيا والوصول الى قصوره الخاصه
القطار مطلي باللونين الاحمر والرمادي ما
يجعله كاي قطار ركاب عادي هو عباره عن
عربه رئاسيه بها غرفه نوم بالاضافه الى
مقصوره مجهزه بمعدات الاتصالات المتطوره
كلف بناؤه اكثر من 13 مليون دولار يقال ان
الرئيس الروسي مقتنع بان السفر فيه اكثر
امانا من ركوب الطائرات التي يسهل تتبعها
الحكايه مختلفه في كييف زيليسكي يحتمي تحت
الارض في مخبا سري يطلق عليه اسمو بانكوفا
وهو كتله خرسانيه من المكاتب المحاطه
بحلقه من الفولاذ تصطف حوله نقاط التفتيش
مع حراس المسلحين لا يسمحون بدخول اي شخص
سوى من لديهم تصريح بذلك ويطلب الجنود من
الموجودين كلمات مرور سريه تتغير يوميا
وغالبا ما تكون عبارات يصعب على الروس
نطقها استخدمه زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته
خلال سيطره الجيش الروسي على بلدات مجاوره
بعد ذلك تغيرت الخطه وخرج زيلينسكي ومن
معه بلال الوجداني العربيه